[Music]
hey everybody this is gonna be my
Justice League Easter eggs video no
surprise they did everything they
possibly could from the DC Universe so
just careful for spoilers from the movie
if you haven't seen it yet but have to
talk about really specific things so the
way I'm gonna do this is this is just
gonna be the Easter eggs and references
from the movie I'm not gonna include too
many of the deleted scenes because
they're all fascinating but I'm gonna do
a separate video next week for all the
deleted scenes that deleted storylines
because they changed the edit they
completely changed the narrative of the
film
so that'll all happen next week but if
you are finding me for the first time be
sure to subscribe to get everything
I'm also doing that IMAX ticket giveaway
for the rest of the year all you have to
do to enter is be a subscriber and leave
a comment on the video announce the
winners at the end of videos so starting
with the biggest thing first
the one thing that everybody's been
confused about since they announced
Aquaman a couple years ago unite the
seven because there's this larger Green
Lantern conversation going on it and
obviously the whole point of Justice
League was to get the team together but
even if you include Superman there are
only six members so people are like
who's the seventh member
what does unite the seven mean it was
revealed recently that it actually has
nothing to do with Justice League it's
an Aquaman thing and it's a reference to
unite the seven seas which was a new 52
storyline Geoff Johns was getting ready
to write this big Aquaman run but then
rebirth happened so they cancelled their
plans and they incorporated most of that
story line into the Aquaman movie the
seven seas is a reference to the seven
different kingdoms of Atlantis so
Atlantis is a city but it's also a
nation so they'll deal with Aquaman
taking the throne the uniting of the
Atlantean nation or maybe the
Reformation of the nation during the
Aquaman movie but speaking of Atlantis
stuff that big Steppenwolf flashback
scene you spotted a whole bunch of stuff
during that so most people were freaking
out about the nameless Green Lantern and
he isn't a specific one from the comics
because this is taking place about five
thousand years ago in the oldest green
lantern that we know about in Sector two
eight one four which is the sector that
earth resides in is Yellin ger and he
was around about two thousand years ago
so we're still way off so this isn't
intended to be any specific
Green Lantern just evidence that the
Green Lantern Corps exists in the
universe and they're out there somewhere
the connection you could make though is
that because this is the Green Lantern
of Earth's sector this would be the ring
that would eventually pass to abend sir
that would eventually pass to Hal Jordan
within that sequence you also spotted an
Atlantean wearing the same armor in a
crown that looks like Aquaman's wielding
the same Trident that's King at land the
original king of Atlantis so they're
just saying that he's Aquaman's ancestor
and obviously there's a lot of deleted
scenes from Atlantis in the Justice
League movie so you don't actually see
him swimming to get the armor and the
Trident but that's what he does after
this moment here when he gets done
arguing with mera so there's just like a
lot of Atlantis stuff that got deleted
out of the movie they'll deal with that
during the Aquaman movie you spot one of
the Amazonian gods obviously because
he's wielding lightning powers you
assumed that it's Zeus that's pretty
much who it is so obviously it's before
the big rebellion before Ares kills the
rest of the gods before the creation of
Themis Kira but after the creation of
the Amazons because you spot Hippolyta
here you spot Robin right pens character
she's kind of blurry because of all the
CG but she did come back to shoot these
scenes Steppenwolf mentions the death of
the old gods when he comes back in
present day the old gods are dead he
talks about ending his exile and taking
his rightful place as one of the new
gods
so that's them teasing Darkseid and the
new gods universe who knows how long
it's gonna be before we see them in a
movie but it does raise some interesting
questions about how you transition from
the old gods to the new gods because the
old gods of the new gods comic books the
fourth world comics are a little bit
different from the gods of the Wonder
Woman comics so what the DC movies might
do is they might just combine those
ideas where by the power of the old gods
can't be killed it's just transferred to
the new gods
so Darkseid - ooh gosh just absorbed all
of the energy that was given off when
Wonder Woman's gods died but for those
of you asking about the MacGuffin the
mother boxes why he kept saying the word
mother that's also part of a deleted
storyline is a slight change to the way
mother boxes work in the comics he's
talking to his literal mother Hydra her
essence is contained in the mother boxes
in is part of that deleted
storyline it was this whole different
plan to wield the power to fight
darkside but they turned it into more of
a terraforming thing so that's not so
much an easter egg it's more of a
deleted scenes thing that I'll just add
to that video the statue that Wonder
Woman is standing on at the beginning of
the film is Themis a Titan from Greek
mythology the sword that she wields is
actually a representation of her ability
to divide right and wrong
so she's literally standing on a
representation of the old gods of
Mythology which also sort of feeds into
the idea of the new gods darkside
apocalypse you remember the exploding
wind-up penguins line from Alfred that's
just a reference to all the really campy
Batman stuff from the 66 movie even from
the Tim Burton movies with the windup
toys that exploded they had a room with
special armor like they did during the
89 Batman film like he had the Japanese
armor you see a version of that here
they also use the 89 Batman
Danny Elfman theme because Danny Elfman
scored the film he worked at a couple
bars of that when they were meeting with
Gordon they also used a bit of the John
Williams theme when Superman comes back
Pet Sematary style cyborg did his
catchphrase from the comics booyah that
probably got one of the biggest cheers
in my theater the actor who played Jimmy
Olsen from the 78th Superman film was
playing one of the prison guards when he
calls Batman to alert him that the flash
is in proximity he's coming to the
prison trying to track him down he uses
an app that's the red Batphone from the
60s TV series Superman racing the flash
is one of the best things ever they race
each other a couple times during the
movie and then there was that funny
scene where Superman kind of inches him
out with his eyeball like letting you
know that he's almost as fast as the
flash they've raced a number of times in
the comics the first time I talked about
it during my post-credits scene video
was in Superman number 199 it was a race
for charity ended up being a tie the
stakes of the race in the movie are just
callbacks to jokes from earlier like the
brunch thing or you're off the team
Barry loves to be on the team he's also
really weird about brunch it was a weird
retroactive Aquaman Easter Egg for the
Man of Steel movies so Jason Momoa
revealed that when they were shooting
justice league he talked to zack snyder
about the Man of Steel sequence where
he's saving people out in the ocean on
the oil rig and he's like
it'd be cool if Aquaman were there he
said that Schneider revealed to him yes
that was my intention that Aquaman was
there to help him out because there's a
moment where it sort of Rises out of the
ocean by itself so just confirmation
that Aquaman was doing Aquaman's stuff
while Man of Steel was happening
obviously that second post-credit scene
is a reference to the in Justice League
we need a league of our own so it's
gonna start with Deathstroke and Lex
Luthor presumably they'll grab a couple
of the other evil characters we've seen
so far maybe some Suicide Squad
characters Lex has his head shaved like
classic gene Hackman Lex Luthor and he's
wearing the exact same suit that he wore
during the 78 Superman film but there's
also a line where Lois says kitten
grooming she talks about not doing
regular journalism she's doing all the
fluff pieces that's actually a reference
to the 78 Superman film when Clark Kent
comes to The Daily Planet for the first
time meets Lois Lane she has a joke
about dog grooming I believe because
she's working on a murder case but
there's some fluff peas that he's trying
to get her to write and she tries to
brush him off that's what that's a
reference to there were all kinds of
flash Easter eggs so obviously a lot of
his storyline got deleted they deleted
the iris West character but he's fluent
in gorilla sign language better brush up
on that before we get to the flashpoint
movie so I'm assuming that they're
planning on doing Grodd at some point
otherwise they wouldn't have bothered to
mention him but Barry's father is in
prison they're obviously setting up the
flashpoint storyline he was wrongfully
accused that's just a reference to
reverse-flash killing his mother so
they're just laying track for that to
pay off during flashpoint but in his
lair we find out that he's a big kpop
band he's actually listening to as if it
was your last bye black pink that's the
song that's playing when everything
turns on he has the needful things
episode of Rick and Morty on in the
background most of you even if you
haven't read Pet Sematary the Stephen
King book probably understood what they
meant when they were talking about
Superman coming back wrong Pet Sematary
is a horror story about a little kid
that buries his cat in this Indian
burial ground Cemetery
it comes back to life but it comes back
evil so that's why Barry says is this
gonna be a Pet Cemetery situation and
for those of you that are confused about
why Pet Cemetery is spelled with an S
that's what the title of the Stephen
King story is
Superman returning the do you bleed line
to Batman probably got one of the
biggest shots in my theater you see some
ace chemicals buildings in the
background of Gotham you also see Janice
a corporation which is owned by Roman Co
NASA's company who is the black mask's
so they might be teasing some future
black mass depending on how they changed
their plans for movies Batman standing
on the gargoyle here like this is
actually a reference to the cover from
Detective Comics number 680 to Zack
Snyder obviously does a lot of those
types of things he did it during Batman
V Superman with the panel from Dark
Knight Returns when he says good to see
you working with others again that's a
reference to bat family obviously we
know that Nightwing and Barbara Gordon
and Batgirl are going to be actual
characters that will meet relatively
soon in the DC Universe that's about as
far as you can take it you can assume
Red Hood things based on the Suicide
Squad Joker story but there might be
some time light edits so don't get too
crazy with bat family probably one of
the coolest 78 Superman references is
when Clark is out in the cornfield back
during the middle part of the film he's
wearing the same type of plaid shirt
that was worn by Clark Kent in the 1978
Superman film the end of the film is
sort of a big tease for the new Hall of
Justice is going to be in the old Wayne
Manor obviously he's going to start
fixing it up he says they need six
chairs around a big long table a
reference to the six of them that have
just come together but Wonder Woman says
yes but room for more teasing Green
Lantern's showing up eventually in
possible future members of the Justice
League that they could pull from the
comics one of the coolest Easter eggs is
actually the November 17th release date
that's actually the 25th anniversary of
the death of Superman in the comics but
let me know in the comments have you
spotted any other Easter eggs in the
film that I didn't mention like I said
there's 50 minutes of the film that has
been cut out but I'll talk a little more
about that when I post my deleted scenes
video so that'll drop sometime early
next week obviously we have all the
flash arrow Supergirl TV crossover stuff
happening so just look out for that to
drop to congratulations to the latest
giveaway winner Andrew Suarez please
private message me on the back end of my
channel so I can get your contact
details I'll announce a new winner when
I post new DC you can click here for my
post credit scene video and you can
click here for the new crossover trailer
video
thank you so much for watching everybody
stay awesome I'll see you guys tonight